let's go right back to the phone let's
go to brit in fort worth texas
brit good morning how are we doing
good morning john thank you for taking
my call
um i'm kind of going through a tough
tough a difficult time right now because
me and my husband are now going through
the process of divorce
i hate that for you i'm so sorry and
it's kind of like
right now it's like we're now able to
talk to each other now
where we can talk now i guess because
the word marriage is not kind of on the
table anymore
but it's like trying to move forward so
it's like how do you rebuild yourself
once coming from this situation like
because it's
it's my feelings are going back and
forth like divorce or no divorce
and we have four kids together so it's
like do i need to really go forward with
this or do i need to
just go stay the stay the path and just
go ahead and divorce
and you know let bygones be bygones
so one of my general rules is this is
i'm never going to tell somebody
except in rare situations that you need
to go get divorced right now
okay that's a that's a trauma that is a
deep life change that shouldn't be taken
lightly
and some knucklehead on the radio
shouldn't pop off and recommend that
um but i will ask a couple of questions
and
and help you walk me through where
you're where you're at
the first thing is you said you're in
the process so have you filed on him or
has he filed on you where
what does that mean you're in the
process it's it's we've both said that
we
we want a divorce okay but then it's
like we neither one of us have actually
went and took that extra step
to go down and file so why do you
want a divorce why did you tell your
husband you're you know what it's time i
want a divorce
he's not loving me the way he needs to
love me like i love him more than
he probably can love me and i put him
before everything else
and he has controlling behavior he's
he's a narcissist and
it's getting to the point now like where
you're locking me out of my phone
you're basically keeping me away from my
friends and family
it's it's gotten to that point where now
i've
given excuses to you for years and now
it's
it's gotten to the point now it's we
have four kids i have three boys
and i don't want my sons growing up
thinking that this is the kind of
behavior that you're supposed to display
to a woman
um gotcha and then we have a daughter
and i don't want my daughter to think
that this is how a man's supposed to
treat you when she gets to that age of
dating
so you just rattled off some things that
you're worried about your kids
and i think those are noble and i think
this idea of
setting examples putting out models for
your kids to follow is
critical and super important but right
now i want to talk about you
you said that you don't think he loves
you like he's supposed to
be more specific for me you said he's
locking you out of your phone
he changes your password on your phone
yeah
what are some other ways well he
constantly accuses me of
of cheating and i'm i mean there's no
reason to do it
but i mean he served in the military and
he's
been vulnerable so there's no telling of
what it could possibly be
or what is going on are you safe
are you emotionally safe
because of what's going on like i can't
be vulnerable with him i can't open up
and say
what's on my what's on my mind and
what's going on
without feeling the fear of judgment or
feeling like he's gonna throw it to the
wayside
because i went through four pregnancies
with him
and i had postpartum depression really
bad and you know you really need that
connection
and you need someone there to give you
that
assurance and i wasn't able to get that
assurance have you and him want to see a
counselor together
have you ever gone and talked to
somebody at your local church or a
couple that you trust
is to say hey what's going on how come
no why not
he's got a psych degree and it's kind of
like he's got that
he's got that whole i i have the
psychology degree and i know
what they're going to say and i know how
they feel and that's what it is
kind of mentality what about you have
you gone to see somebody
i've spoken to a lot of different people
and everybody's basically you know
everybody
has their own type of opinion of how to
approach this going forward no no i'm
not talking about just a bunch of
random people i'm talking about have you
gone to a counselor yourself
i did when i was going through
postpartum depression but i did not talk
to them about my marriage or anything
okay brit i think before you do anything
you need to go sit down with a
professional with someone that
is skilled in talking about marriages
that is skilled
in um helping people
walk through what your next steps should
be and that you can
really dig into your relationship your
four kids and what your future
might or might not look like you owe
that to yourself
you deserve brit i want you to hear me
are you hearing me
yes you deserve to be well
you're a mom of four beautiful babies
three knucklehead little boys and a
beautiful little girl
and you deserve to be a fully whole
mom something here doesn't sound right
to me
something here sounds a little bit i
i just imagine if we sat down for an
hour or two there would be a whole lot
more to this story so this is one that's
just hard to unwind in 10 minutes or 15
minutes on a radio call
and that's why i'm i'm just gonna plead
with you to go
speak with somebody i wish wish
wish your husband would too my guess is
he's got a long story to tell as well
and that he's dealing with his own um
challenges
and he would benefit greatly from having
an environment where he could be
vulnerable and talk to people what's
going on
but there is a lot lot here
backing out 30 000 feet here's my my
couple of words on divorce
first thing is you got four kids a
divorce
is going to be a major life change for
y'all
and so again it's not something to be
taken lightly it's not something just to
ask
random people at a bingo hall or at a
church
or at the grocery store this is
something to be taken very very
seriously
the second thing is is there is
something in your voice that makes me
wonder
what wholeness looks like what safety
looks like
and i want you to find a professional
and i also want you to find a mentor
an older woman who maybe has been down
this road before in your community that
you can just sit down
not in a flyby but someone's going to
spend a couple hours with you that you
can sit down and just
let all this out and talk that can be a
guiding light for you divorce is no joke
but being in an unsafe
relationship is no joke either for
everybody out there struggling with this
idea of should i get divorced should i
not
it feels like everybody does it right it
feels like this real
common thing you know you hear the stats
thrown around one out of two
one out of three whatever the numbers
happen to be on whatever given
internet article pops up here's the
thing
we hear it so often that we think it's
just this easy thing to do and it's
not divorce is hard it is
a loss i tell people to treat it like
the death of somebody
and it's sometimes harder than a death
because the person's not dead
you can't fully grieve them being gone
because they're still there and if you
have four kids
you're still gonna have a relationship
with them for the foreseeable future
right so get some wisdom in your life
get a professional get a friend
and um thanks for the call brit thanks
for being vulnerable and being open
but you are right you need to go talk to
somebody i could hear it in your voice
and
um call me back when you make some
decisions i'd love to hear where
your next steps are going to go and if
we can help you
man make the next crooked wobbly step as
you figure out what's next so
let us know how things are going